it's the next big scandal waiting to
happen
a former prime minister under fire after
weeks of silence david cameron who
himself in 2010 warned about lobbying
has admitted he shouldn't have emailed
or texted cabinet ministers on behalf of
greenfield capital
but as pressure builds for an
investigation he also defended his right
to represent the businesses
interests at the very heart of
government
employed by lex greensell to advise his
financial services company mr cameron
wasn't a lobbyist
but the methods he used to win influence
are under the microscope nonetheless
his text to chancellor rishi sunak's
personal phone and a private drink with
health secretary matt hancock all
designed to win favor for the company he
stood to gain
millions from have focused attention on
who has the ear of the cabinet
now finally he has addressed the
criticism claiming the company's ideas
were good and its backers high profile
was sound financial judgment
in a lengthy statement mr cameron said
in my representations to government i
was breaking no
codes of conduct and no government rules
the registrar of consultant lobbyists
has found that my activities did not
fall within the criteria that require
registration
ultimately the outcome of the
discussions i encouraged about how green
sales proposals might be included in the
government ccff initiative
and help in the wake of the coronavirus
crisis was that they were not taken up
however i have reflected on this at
length there are important lessons to be
learnt
as a former prime minister i accept that
communications with government needs to
be done through only the most formal of
channels
so there can be no room for
misinterpretation
although the treasury says mr cameron's
tactics didn't change the outcome in
this case there are still big questions
about whether greensell's ability to
meet face-to-face with cabinet ministers
like matt hancock
helped the company win contracts which
ultimately mr cameron stood to gain
financially from
what this really comes down to is how
much influence the former holders of
this prestigious office
should keep once they leave it some
believe the rules for former ministers
must now change
it's about a level playing field the
private sector
should all have a similar access to
government
and there's no reason why the prime
minister or the
chief executive of the company couldn't
have just written to the treasury
in the same way that any other company
asking for
some uh advice uh and help but they
didn't do that
they used ex prime minister
to really put the screws on the treasury
to try and get
help in their financial with their
financial problems
mr cameron will hope that his statement
puts an end to accusations he acted
inappropriately in seeking to influence
senior cabinet ministers
but it's unlikely to in reality this
episode will reignite a tricky political
debate about how former ministers should
be allowed to use their contacts
after they leave office kate mccann sky
news